My wife and I found out earlier in the year and we may not be able to have
children.
Then last month I was diagnosed with cancer.
Okay.
Oh man,
how do I combat depression?
Well,
the first thing that we should point out here,
I'm very sorry to hear about all that.
That's,
that's a lot of tragedy in a very short period of time.
And,
um,
and I'm not going to give you any casual advice because,
but I,
maybe I can make some things clearer.
The first is you're not depressed.
You've had terrible things happen to you.
That's not the same thing.
Right.
Okay.
I distinguished between them.
If a client comes to me and they say they're feeling very sad and down and
anxious and worried about everything and so forth,
then I kind of walked through their life.
Do they have friends?
Do they have a family?
Do they have a meaningful job?
It,
is their educational background appropriate for their level of intelligence and
ability?
Are they taking care of themselves?
Do they have something to look forward to?
Did they use their time outside of work productively and wisely,
et cetera.
So you think about those as the dimensions of a good life.
There's more,
or maybe there's fewer,
but that's not too bad for a quick and dirty first pass through,
let's say.
Um,
those are the dimensions by the way,
that you work on.
If you do the future authoring program in the self authoring suite,
you're asked to think about all those dimensions and consider what your life
might be like if you optimized along all of them.
And so,
um,
if you,
if all of those things are going well for you and you feel terrible all the
time,
then you're depressed.
Okay.
Cause there's,
there's something wrong with your emotional regulation.
You know,
I mean,
maybe you're having an existential crisis that's a possibility,
but I mean,
let's assume we can't see anything structurally wrong with your life,
but you're feeling terrible.
Then I would say,
well,
you have depression.
There's something wrong.
Maybe it's physiological and people like that.
In my experience,
those are the people who often really benefit from antidepressants.
But then there's other sort of person who who is in trouble.
You know,
they,
their educational attainment is not what it should be.
They don't have a job.
They have an alcohol or drug problem.
They have a family that's really not functioning well or they don't have a
family.
Their immediate relationship,
intimate relationship is nonexistent or terrible.
Um,
their friends are non existent or,
or,
or worthless and,
and destructive.
Um,
they don't get along with their relatives there in poor mental and physical
health.
You get the picture that's,
and they're not feeling good.
There are moods low and they're anxious.
That's not depression.
Like it might be,
you know,
but it's a terror.
But what that is,
is a terrible life.
And,
and those are different things they needed to be,
they need to be conceptualized differently.
Now even if you have a terrible life,
an antidepressant might be able to lift you up enough so that you can keep
fighting.
Let's say,
assuming that that's what you're doing,
but an antidepressant obviously isn't going to help,
isn't going to remove the facts of your terrible life.
Now you,
you've got terrible things happening to you at the moment and,
and there's no simple answer to that.
I would say you could,
you could take a look at chapter 12 in my book,
12 rules for life.
It's,
it's called a pet,
a cat when you encounter one on the street.
And in part it's a,
it's an autobiography I autobiographical chapter about how my wife and I and my
family,
my,
my son and daughter and my,
my extended family as well dealt with my daughter's extremely serious illness
while she,
it's still,
it's still plagues are to some degree,
although not nearly as much as it did.
She was very seriously ill when she was a teenager and a,
it was an ongoing crisis,
a continual for years of crisis.
And so the question is how do you cope with that?
And the answer is,
the first answer is you shrink your timeframe.
You know,
you've had these,
especially with regards to your diagnosis.
So like
all of a sudden your future has been thrown completely into chaos and
you don't know how to deal with that.
And who would you do what you can to stabilize your medical treatment and to
optimize your quality of life while that's happening.
Very complicated thing to do.
And then I would say you live for the day,
you know,
for the week maybe,
maybe a week's too much even,
but for the day it's like you get up in the morning,
you think I need to do everything I can to make this day as meaningful and and
rich as I possibly can.
And hopefully I will have had a full day by this evening and then I'll be able
to sleep and then I'll be able to get up in the morning and say,
I'm going to try to make this day as useful and meaningful and engaging as it
can be.
And then maybe when you're really sick,
you don't have a day,
you have hours and then you do the same thing for the hours.
And then maybe you do the same thing with the minutes.
I would also say,
you know,
you've been through a lot of shock and it's conceivable that you might need to
talk to someone.
It's also conceivable that an antidepressant could help you,
you know,
you've got a lot to deal with and you might need your nervous system might need
some stabilization with all that stress.
And so that's something to consider.
Antidepressants are also quite effective as pain medications,
especially a drug called.
So that's also worth knowing because you need to know about effective pain
medication.
It's very important,
um,
in extreme situations of pain.
Opiates of course are the drug of choice,
but you could use drugs like methylphenidate,
Ritalin,
the Adhd drug,
you can use them as adjuncts to,
to pain medication.
And people need to know that because the,
the,
um,
there basically amphetamines,
amphetamines have analgesic properties,
but they also keep,
they also maintain alertness.
And so the problem with opiates is they can be sedating,
but an opiate amphetamine combination.
And this is for people who are in absolutely intractable pain,
by the way,
um,
that can increase alertness and help cope with pain.
And it's really useful to know what you might need to cope with pain.
So I would say shrink your time horizon and then,
oh,
thank you.
Okay,
thanks Tim.
Shrink your time horizon and then concentrate on the
concentrate on the moment.
Whatever that moment happens to be,
might be the next minute,
you know?
I don't know what else to do when you're in an extreme situation.
The other thing,
I guess the final thing I would say with regards to the,
we may not have be able to have children.
Well,
you need a plan to address that to the best that that you can to the best way
that you can.
And then you have to give yourself some time to reconceptualize your life and
your future.
And I would say news,
like we may not be able to have children that probably takes about a year or
year and a half to digest.
So don't be too hard on yourself if you haven't figured it out yet.
It's any major life transformation,
like a really major life transformation.
I would say it takes a minimum of a year to really adapt to.